c'est ici mon ancien cabinet donc au
boulevard Rondeau
c'était il y a 15 jours quelqu'un se
présente je lui dis que c'est complet il
peut revenir l'après-midi me demander
juste c'est juste pour une radio je dis
bon il s'est fait mal je peux toujours
demander la radio il revient après pour
voir les choses donc j'ai demandé de
patienter et il n'a pas supporté donc je
rentre dans mon bureau il a étant pour
une sur la porte j'ouvre je croyais que
c'est quelqu'un qui a fait un malaise
et non tu me donnes l'ordonnance
son copain qui était dehors pourquoi tu
lui parles comme ça pour que tu te
prends et puis il voulait me frapper et
je me suis dit
déjà qu'est-ce que je fais là il a
raison pour qui je me prends je me
prends pour un médecin qui est dans son
cabinet qui soigner les gens ou je suis
là pour
subir les insultes du premier venu donc
ça a été ça c'était ça c'était un
électroshock donc l'avenir il s'inscrit
pour moi ici avec mes patients toujours
les mêmes on est trois quatre kilomètres
de mon ancien cabinet au début on s'en
rend pas compte au début on a de manière
isolé des incivilités de mécontentements
des gestes agressifs mais bon on dit bon
après tout ça arrive bien un peu partout
c'est quand ça devient répétitif quand
ça devient fréquent c'est là on se dit
mais il se passe quelque chose il y a un
changement qui est en train de
s'installer dans dans le quartier dans
la société dans la patientèle quand
j'arrive à un moment quand je rentre à
la maison et que mes enfants posent la
question papa est arrivé aujourd'hui je
me suis dit il y a un problème
et pas cette nouvelle délinquance qui
vient de s'installer ça fait peut-être
bien deux trois ans ou
ça augmente et on l'a vu arriver est-ce
qu'il faut déplacer tous les médecins
tous les commerces parce que les gens
ont peur tous les vieux toutes les
personnes qui veulent aller travailler
tous les professeurs qui vont travailler
parce qu'on fait on les laisse on s'en
va le docteur il est parti mais c'était
pour le docteur de
pour un refus
d'arrêt de travail
qui était bien entendu in justifié donc
c'est c'est clair on a mis tout mon
bureau par terre moi j'entends le
mécontentement des gens je l'entends je
le comprends mais quand on devient
agressif ou physiquement ça je l'accepte
pas c'est arrivé qu'une fois une
agression physique c'est-à-dire que je
remonte le cabinet il y a une dizaine de
personnes qui attendent déjà et si vous
voulez une fois que les gens sont
installés qui a un ordre de passage il y
a quelqu'un qui rentre qui dit je passe
tout de suite
évidemment personne n'est d'accord avec
ça bon le médecin c'est celui qui
tranche
urgent c'est pas urgent en l'occurrence
ce n'était pas urgent donc j'ai refusé
bien entendu et là ça n'a pas plu donc
j'ai pris un coup sur le visage on m'a
cassé mes lunettes ou ma griffé enfin
bref ça a été c'était une dame donc bon
c'est compliqué de répondre j'ai fait
appel à la police qui s'est déplacé j'ai
porté plainte sans suite je me fais pas
justice moi-même je porte plainte je
fais appel aux autorités à la loi
mais la suite
laisse croire que
on n'a pas beaucoup de droits quand on
est agressé dans son cabinet
fasse beaucoup plus mais si les élus
locaux ne font rien avant il y avait le
marché qui dimanche maintenant le marché
c'est tous les jours c'est le marché
c'est une brocante que le marché mais
peut-être que quand on habite pas à cet
endroit là il faut que Monsieur sa fille
commence à tôt elle est obligé de
l'accompagner pour qu'elle prenne le
métro c'est pas normal moi je reçois des
patients qui viennent en larmes en
détresse parce qu'on leur a chez leur
sac leur portable quand quelqu'un en
voiture me dit quand je suis seul dans
ma voiture je traverse pas le rond-point
du capitaine geste ce n'est pas normal
ça m'est arrivé de partir du cabinet de
m'arrêter parce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui
s'est pris une balle dans la rue et de
l'assister en attendant l'arrivée du
SAMU et ça je ne sais pas combien de
fois il faut le dire pour qu'on puisse
l'entendre il y a ur pourquoi en tolère
dans le 15e quand on les repas au Prado
ou la Canebière dans le 8ème
arrondissement pourquoi on n'arrive pas
à Marseille
on n'arrive pas à assurer la sécurité de
la population je pense que c'est ça la
question
[Applaudissements]
oui monsieur bon c'est pas ok en effet
mais comme c'est pas urgent je vous
ferai la prochaine fois si vous voulez
d'accord
ok au revoir merci
moi je suis diplômé de la faculté de
médecine de Paris 11 où j'ai exercé un
SOS Médecins une dizaine d'années et
après j'ai fait le choix en famille de
venir
m'installer à Marseille on a fait le
choix de quitter Paris et de venir
chercher chercher le soleil chercher une
meilleure qualité de vie
qu'effectivement
nous avons retrouvé à Marseille j'avais
envie aussi de venir dans ce quartier
quartier nord de Marseille devenir dans
ces quartiers là pour essayer pour mieux
connaître les gens et d'apporter en tout
cas d'incompétence à cette population et
où en effet il y a pas beaucoup de
médecins qui viennent spontanément
s'installer dans ces quartiers il y a
Marseille et puis il y a le quartier
Nord on dirait un petit territoire
satellite complètement coupé de la ville
et en plus bon j'avais une orientation
enfin j'ai toujours une orientation sur
la diabétologie et les quartiers nord se
distinguent on est rencontre beaucoup de
diabète beaucoup d'obésité beaucoup
d'insuffisance respiratoire beaucoup de
maladies cardiovasculaires beaucoup
d'asthmes et je géoca mal à m'installer
avoir ma patientèle je suis venu un peu
soulager certainement des confrères qui
étaient débordés déjà à l'époque qui
avait des difficultés à répondre à la
demande pendant de très longues années
j'ai une activité très satisfaisante
très intéressante j'ai pas du tout à me
plaindre ni du quartier ni de la
population c'était j'ai envie de
extraordinaire pendant de très longues
années jusqu'à
il y a pas longtemps alors on est
toujours dans les quartiers nord mais il
faut pas penser que quartier nord c'est
c'est la jungle que c'est non c'est un
secteur de Marseille qui est très
agréable il y a des gens très
sympathiques ou tout n'est pas violence
malheureusement il y a quelques îlots
quelques quartiers il y a quelques
points mais je reste dans le quartier
Nord j'y tiens l'avenir il s'inscrit
pour moi ici avec mes patients toujours
les mêmes
on a du mal à y aller ailleurs
parce que lui connaît non mon cœur non
pas et je dirais pas c'est un simple
docteur c'est dans cette médecine si
quelqu'un qui se casse la tête pour s'y
patience c'est quelqu'un qui oriente
mais je suis ici à votre disposition et
je ferai de le maximum malheureusement
c'est une plus loin de chez moi je vais
jusqu'à ici mais j'ai pas le choix donc
on doit le suivre
mon travail de médecin de famille je
vous connaissais depuis très très
longtemps avant même que vous ayez fondé
votre famille
les enfants j'ai une passionne en tout
cas qui est très très variée du bébé qui
vient de naître jusqu'à la mamie donc je
vois les gens pas ordre d'arrivée il y a
pas de il y a pas de rendez-vous ensuite
des problèmes non parce que non le
rendez-vous le rendez-vous c'est une
difficulté supplémentaire parce qu'on
donne des rendez-vous des gens qui dans
la moitié les trois quarts ne viennent
pas pourquoi parce que les gens quand
ils prennent ils prennent rendez-vous si
tu ne contrainte qu'ils ont
supplémentaire qui ne supportent pas ou
qui n'assume pas il préfère venir et
attendre donc j'ai tout essayé
finalement quand les gens arrivent je
leur donne les rendez-vous sur place
donc je donne un ticket
un ordre j'ai établi un ordre de passage
par ordre d'arrivée en dehors des
urgences allô
oui alors qu'est-ce que ça donnait la
radio non non c'est pas grave
[Musique]
laissez-moi votre numéro de téléphone je
vous appelle d'accord voilà merci ok
de s'installer dans ces quartiers dans
les quartiers populaires dans certains
quartiers en tout cas que certains
désertent je pense que c'est vraiment là
on fait de la vraie médecine quand on a
envie d'être médecin de famille quand on
a envie de voir les gens comme ils sont
quand on a envie d'être utile aux gens
c'est dans ces quartiers là où tout le
sens de
médecin de famille vraiment
[Musique]
et juste donc moi j'invite vraiment les
médecins de pas s'éloigner de ces zones
là et de bien qu'il y ait quelques
difficultés bien que c'est des fois un
peu compliqué
c'est très satisfaisant et gratifiant
d'exercer dans ces quartiers les
patients arrivent seul à la porte
ensuite je vois ici si qui est là et en
fonction en fonction effectivement
s'il y a quoi que ce soit je peux ouvrir
ou pas avec la commande qui est ici
voilà et comme ça donc j'ai
un système comme comme une banque
maintenant
ce métier qui est un métier
extraordinaire le métier de soignant et
aujourd'hui à vivre vraiment une crise
vraiment très grave dernier chiffre par
exemple publié par le conseil de l'ordre
ont montré combien les médecins ont été
agressés c'est en augmentation la perte
de vocation d'un médecin déjà et les
liée à
beaucoup de d'éléments que de
l'installation de la revalorisation de
ce métier de l'image de ce métier si en
plus on protège pas les médecins quand
ils sont agressés je pense aussi ça
donne raison à beaucoup de médecins qui
soient qui se détournent de ce métier
c'est le cas de mes enfants aucun n'a
voulu faire médecine trois enfants aucun
a voulu faire médecine aujourd'hui il y
a 10% de diplômés qui s'installe les 90%
ils vont où pourquoi on refuse
aujourd'hui de s'installer dans un
cabinet médical à un moment donné il va
alors peut-être se pencher sur ce
problème sérieusement
[Musique]
je pense que vous serez
en meilleure
endroit ici que
d'accord
on a déplacé le problème tout à fait je
regrette effectivement mais j'ai fait ce
que j'ai pu ma démarche n'est pas une
démarche pour polémiquer ce que je dis à
mes patients
j'ai eu la chance on va dire de pouvoir
quitter le quartier tout le monde n'a
pas cette chance là j'essaie de porter
la parole de ceux qui ne qui crient dans
le silence j'essaie de porter cette
parole